hey everybody Ken Coleman here it's time
for another episode of backseat driver
what I love so much about this is the
stories that we get to hear and share
with you and when I think of story and
the importance of the role it plays in
our own lives well I can't think of a
better person to have conversation with
about story than my guest today hey dude
see you I'm great
oh you went with the Volkswagen in the
backseat today is Donald Miller a
student of story don has written several
New York Times bestsellers like scary
clothes and blue light jazz which is now
a major motion picture his storyline
blog is currently helping people every
day to live a better story I can't wait
to share his story and I hope it changes
yours when do you first realise I think
I want to write when I was a kid in
junior high I actually attended the high
school talent show I just asked my youth
pastor down at the local church hey can
I ride a review of the talent show you
know like a movie review sure for the
youth group newsletter which goes out to
like you know 80 people and he goes yeah
he didn't wanna write the column that
way so yeah and you know people kept
stopping me in the hall of Church saying
wow you're actually a really good writer
now I'm in junior high right and that's
the first time anybody had ever really
affirmed me or anything that I I'd done
somebody saying hey you're good at this
and I sort of chased those accolades in
writing until ten fifteen years later
wrote my first book at some point you
begin to shift your thinking as to what
you're doing I want you to describe that
for us
I loved running my conference I loved
speaking at my conference and but the
problem was only had about 350 people
coming to each conference I couldn't
figure out why do I have millions of
readers and then when I do a conference
only 350 people come so I actually got
on a plane one day and the guy sitting
next to me on the plane was reading my
latest book which the conference is
based on and I said how do you like that
book and he looked at me and he said I
really like this book in fact I'm flying
to Indianapolis today to hear this guy
speak I said really cuz I hear that
guy's kind of a jerk
and he just looked a little bit offended
and said like you know I don't never met
him but I don't I've never heard that
that he's a jerk and just not making the
connection but what I had Ken was I had
two hours with a guy to ask questions
about my quote unquote brand what I
discovered was that he was a big fan but
couldn't articulate very clearly how I
changed his life or really who I was and
then it occurred to me the reason that
the word isn't spreading about my
conference is because I'm not giving
people the words to say so that it can
spread people really need simple simple
messaging and so I worked on my
messaging through the filter of story
everything that I'd ever learned about
telling stories which is the most
powerful tool to compel human brain how
do we use that story breakdown to figure
out what our role is how we interact
with others how overwhelming life and
the big story is if we miss this yeah
well a story is a character that wants
something it overcomes conflict to get
it story is really just a condensed
version of life and so what would happen
if our life you and I were to sit down
and say okay let's get clear about what
my life story is the power of a great
writer comes when they are willing to
throw things out I think the last book I
turned in when I finished it it was a
hundred and ten thousand words and when
I published it it was fifty four
thousand Wow
so more than 50% of that book was thrown
away and that's the power also of
creating a great life plan it's so much
the stuff just needs to go
you need to clarify one or two things
that you really want to accomplish we
need to have a relationship with
conflict that is not conflict avoidant
but we need to move into it those little
things that work to create a great
screenplay also work to create a great
life mmm that's good
all right now can you sign some books
here I want to keep digging into the
story thing yeah
you ever been in here no this is cool
book man book woman Nashville Tennessee
hi how are you I'm Ken this is dawn how
are you what's your favorite Don Dahler
boy do you have one blue light Jay Otis
oh thanks you have the new and scary
clothes we did we made these all day up
old to be a best-selling author you look
at this bookstore and they're just full
of stories and what it what it tells us
is that the human brain longs for story
the way we want the food and water we
just have to have them I mean in America
we will spend ten billion dollars next
year at the box office and all we're
buying our stories that's right used
bookstores are my favorite you know the
real Jim is when you get a used book and
it's got somebody else's notes in it
right and you're then you realized
you're not alone writing this book many
people that's cool
they're like handing the baton - yeah
that's got something out of this now
here's your exactly what's great about a
book store like this is that they've
managed to stay open with Amazon 50
percent of my books sell through Amazon
50 percent through one store
tell me about writing your first book
well I was actually working at a
publishing company when I started
writing and I wanted to be a writer
before I worked the publishing company
but once I got a job with a company I
saw that writers weren't there you know
the dream of like the romantic writers
life and you can even you can't you can
never be a writer just kind of went away
when I saw who they actually Porter
right they're just insecure folks like
me tell us what were you doing for the
publishing company at that time what
specific day-to-day it was a small
publishing company and I got a I got
started at the bottom and in four years
I was president of the company hello and
yeah so I love business and I love books
and it got to bring those two worlds
together and I just thrived in that
environment and at night I would go home
and tinker with a book and I remember I
was at common ground coffee shop in
Portland Oregon I can show you the chair
if it's still there I was sitting in and
I wrote one paragraph and I knew this is
going to go all the way to the end of
the book I'm gonna keep going I just
knew it I just knew it it was just a
great paragraph and
and I think that's all that sorry that's
all any writers trying to do is find a
good sentence alright
talked a lot about story why is it so
important that each of us live a good
story with our lives you know the story
Robert McKee is this guru on story is
really a brilliant guy and he talks
about the fact that when you hear
stories what's happening in your brain
is that there's a moral compass being
set and I used to think the number one
way we consume stories was movies and
television those sorts of things may be
books but I've come the realization
that's just not true the number one way
we consume stories is through each other
that you're actually living a story and
I'm living story in other words you can
are setting the moral compass in my
brain you're teaching me what's worth
pursuing you're teaching me what's worth
sacrificing for and that's adjusting
things in my brain so the reason we
should live a great story is because if
we live a great story our kids are
learning what's beautiful in life what's
worth sacrificing for our neighbors are
learning that and and then they start
living different stories because their
compass has been adjusted to it couldn't
be more important to live a great story
pretty cool to come to an independent
bookstore I know and look sleep with
books free books you got a little man
book woman not books in a city no you
ready to go get back in the bug I'm
ready
actually I want to show you my VW you
show me yours
it's a rear-engine just like the old
bugs and buses you can actually pull
this engine out by yourself oh you got
to take me first bin let's go